ça veut dire que il nécessairement ça va
être dépassé paris fait beaucoup plus
attention que ses prédécesseurs aux
questions vert non seulement parce que
c'est à la mode mais aussi parce que le
cio s'est quand même aperçu a senti
passer le vent du boulet
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour 1h30 d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en direct une émission
essentiellement consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus en france et dans le monde
la france a passé la barre des 12 milles
morts liés à l'épidémie et compte 4 124
nouveaux décès en 24 heures annonce du
directeur général de la santé il ya
quelques instants
alors que les français restent dans
l'incertitude en cette quatrième semaine
de confinement le président macron doit
s'exprimer lundi il a rencontré cet
après midi à marseille le confesseur
parfois à controversé didier rahout face
à la crise la france relève son plan
d'urgence à 100 milliards d'euros
[Musique]
épidémie de coronavirus dans le monde
plus de 90 mille décès enregistrés au
total nouveau la triste record au
royaume uni et dans l'état de new york
qui comptabilisent respectivement 8 181
morts supplémentaires et 799 ces
dernières 24 heures mais la courbe se
réduit en termes d'hospitalisation dans
la ville américaine
en italie on apprend qu'une centaine de
médecins au total ont été tuées par le
coronavirus
[Musique]
la conférence élargie entre pays
producteurs de pétrole elle est cruciale
pour tenter de trouver un équilibre
alors que la demande d'or noir devrait
chuter en 2020 ce qui n'était plus
arrivé depuis 2009 l'opep et ses dix
partenaires vont essayer de s'accorder
sur des baisses de production afin de
soutenir les prix qui se sont effondrés
avec à la pandémie
[Musique]
elle aura pas divisés sur la réponse
économique à la crise du coronavirus les
ministres des finances de la zone euro
continuent de se déchirer sur les moyens
à mettre en oeuvre face à la récession
qui s'annonce la pire depuis 1945
recours au mécanisme européen de
stabilité
les coraux n'abandonne impliquant une
mutualisation des dettes les blocages
sont nombreux alors que peut-on encore
attendre de l'union européenne dans
cette crise c'est la question à laquelle
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre ce soir dans sa chronique à
21h15
[Musique]
la france totalise donc douze mille
pardons 2000
liste des faits du cornât virus 424
nouveaux décès ont été enregistrés dans
les dernières 24 heures dans les
hôpitaux annonce il y à quelques minutes
de jérôme c'est le mans directeur
général de la santé mais bonne nouvelle
tout de même il ya 82 patients au moins
est en réanimation ce jeudi au total
plus de 23000 personnes sont sortis
guéris de l'hôpital 2002 plus
aujourd'hui demain de nouveaux tgv
médicalisé transféreront des patients de
l'île de france vers la nouvelle équipe
est d'écouter en france nous sommes
confrontés à une situation
exceptionnelle qui s'inscrit dans la
durée
tous ensemble nous devons faire bloc
contre le virus
la maladie l'épidémie respecter le
confinement
la distanciation physique de plus d'un
mètre
tous les gestes barrières et la
réduction volontaire et massive des
contacts grâce à ces mesures
nous sommes en train progressivement de
freiner l'épidémie pour diminuer encore
la pression sur tous nos établissements
de santé sur nos médecins nos infirmiers
et nous aide soignant qui sont en
tension maximale qui travaillent jour et
nuit
nous devons tous ensemble redoubler nos
efforts collectifs et solidaire dans ce
contexte emmanuel macron s'est donc
rendu à marseille cet après midi pour
rencontrer le professeur didier raoult
et une rencontre très symbolique alors
que le chef de l'état mène des
consultations avant de prendre de
nouvelles décisions dans la crise on le
rappelle didier rahout est un fervent
défenseur du traitement à
l'hydrochlorothiazide
devait d'ailleurs présenté les résultats
de ces études au président cet après
midi un traitement qui ne convainc pas
l'ensemble du milieu scientifique et
pour parler de cette crise en france et
de la communication du gouvernement nous
sommes en direct avec jordan bardella
vice président du rassemblement national
député européen bonsoir jean d'annaba
les choix merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france emmanuel macron qui
rend visite à didier raoul ton c'est un
scientifique souvent controversées
pourquoi selon vous cette visite du chef
de l'état aux médecins marseillais
il faudrait lui demander directement ce
que je note c'est que un certain nombre
de médecins aujourd'hui dans le pays
suivent le protocole raul tu avec un
certain un certain succès la réalité et
ça répondra peut-être à votre question
c'est que nous n'avons que ce traitement
aujourd'hui cette hypothétique
traitement pour évidemment faire face à
sète à cette épidémie coronavirus on a
toujours été très clair on a toujours
indiqué nous que la liberté devait être
laisse évidemment aux médecins de
prescrire ce médicament en association
avec un autre c'est un protocole en
réalité avec les prescrits depuis
maintenant plusieurs plusieurs décennies
le gouvernement a été extrêmement
contradictoires sur le sujet parce que
le professeur raout qui n'est quand même
pas le perdreau de l'année qui est quand
même reconnus dans la profession
préconisé un usage de la chloroquine de
l'hydroxyde rockin lors du début des
symptômes lors de symptômes débutants ou
plutôt avancé mais absolument pas dans
des cas graves en le gouvernement a
souhaité lui l'utiliser dans des cas
graves
c'est là évidemment de contradictions
majeures en laquelle il faut mettre fin
maintenant il faut évidemment continuer
de 2,2 d'en faire des tests à une
échelle un peu plus grande
mais la réalité est encore une fois ça
répond à votre question c'est peut-être
que nous avons que ce traitement
aujourd'hui ce potentiel traitement elle
face à un virus étant donné que le
vaccin n'arrivera sans doute pas avant
évidemment l'année prochaine au bas mot
alors on le sait un professeur raoul qui
est souvent à contre courant de ce qui
se pratique dans le reste du pays dans
son institut à marseille patrick
les stages massifs notamment se souvient
de ces files d'attentes devant
l'institut tous les jours un exemple
devrait tenter de suivre le gouvernement
selon vous tel est en tout cas pour
conclure sur le professeur raoul ce
n'est évidemment pas le traitement de
l'irak mais la reine la solution c'est
que nous n'avons que ça pour l'instant
et nous n'avons que ça parce que en
réalité on s'est interdit pendant
plusieurs semaines de recourir à des
tests et là encore le gouvernement a
menti il faut dire les choses très
clairement comme il a menti sur les
masques comme il a menti sur l' usage de
la chloroquine on prend nos voisins
allemands qui eux ont eu recours
massivement à des tests qui ont testé
massivement je vous rappelle que
l'allemagne test environ 500 mille
personnes par semaine et envisage de
quasiment de tripler ce chiffre est de
passer à un million quatre cent mille
tests par semaine quand la france
montrent difficilement à 30 milles par
jour donc on a pris énormément de retard
la corée du sud qui l a d des résultats
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus positive
beaucoup plus optimiste sur cette
épidémie a elle aussi eu recours à une
politique massive de test la réalité
c'est que le la politique du confinement
c'est une politique pour ceux qui n'ont
pas de politique en réalité on utilise
on a utilisé le confinement parce qu'on
n'avait pas d'autres alternatives qu'on
n'avait pas d'autre choix pour casser la
contagion pour désengorger les hôpitaux
maintenant il faudra évidemment il faut
d'ores et déjà évidemment aujourd'hui
réfléchir à une stratégie de
déconfinement on va pas laisser une
population tout entière de confinés
pendant des mois et des mois mon qu'il
faut aujourd'hui évidemment se projeter
bien que la bataille ne soit pas encore
gagné on est très très loin du compte et
recourir massivement une fois que la
population pourra ressortir à des tests
de massifs afin d'abord de pouvoir
déterminer quelles sont les personnes
qui ont acquis une immunité
et puis d'autre part de pouvoir
évidemment placé très très vite au
confinement à l'isolément des gens qui
sont détectés positifs au virus
parce que l'arrêté c'est que on n'a
strictement rien anticipé je vous
rappelle que marine le pen exigé dès la
fin janvier le contrôle des frontières
qu'elle avait interrogé dès le 11
février le 11 février
mais la buse un qui était ministre de la
santé à l'époque sur les stocks de
masques sur les stocks de médicaments
sur le nombre de tests
on nous a expliqué qu'il avait pas de
problème or rien de tout cela n'a été
anticipé
on a sous-estimé on a minimisé cette
épidémie et cela évidemment aujourd'hui
des conséquences très graves
à l'heure où notre armée c'est à dire
nos personnels soignants nos médecins en
blouse blanche se bat avec un matériel
de de pietrus quantité il faut bien
l'admettre alors emmanuel macron va
s'exprimer lundi on sait déjà en lice
que l'elysée elle a indiqué hier que ce
conflit non irait au delà du 15 avril
mais effectivement on parle jamais de
stratégie de déconfinement edouard finit
pas toujours écartée voilà l'idée d'en
parler aux français c'est beaucoup de
nos voisins européens le font pourtant
notamment l'autriche votre réaction
ma réaction c'est que le confinement
aujourd'hui de se poursuivre parce que
en l'état actuel nous n'avons ni masque
ni possibilité de tester la population
qu'évidemment il va nous falloir encore
quelques semaines le temps que
évidemment nous fassions arrivée sur le
territoire national des tests des
masques à défaut d'en fabriquer puisque
par la politique qui a défendu
emmanuel macron n'est pas seulement
d'ailleurs ses prédécesseurs on a laissé
se délocaliser on a organisé des
délocalisations massives de nos filières
stratégiques je vous rappelle que 90%
des médicaments se font à l'étranger et
donc aujourd'hui on est dépendant des
dépendants d'un flux mondial on est
dépendant de pays étrangers comme la
chine qui ont eu aussi à satisfaire une
demande nationale
donc la réalité c'est qu'il nous faut
des masques il nous faut des tests et il
faudra nous le croyons généraliser le
port du masque ali sud à l'issue de ce
confinement a expliqué que les masques
ne servait à rien pour tout simplement
dissimuler le fait qu'il n'avait
absolument pas de masque de stocks de
masques et béton qui justement jean
bardet là je voudrais vous faire écouter
christophe cas sévères il était
auditionné ce matin à l'assemblée
nationale il est revenu le ministre de
l'intérieur sur cette question du port
de masques ils demandent au préfet
concerné d'ailleurs qui ont souhaité des
arrêtés pour le rendre obligatoire
données retirer écouter ce que j'ai
demandé notamment sur les arrêtés qui
prévoit le port du masque obligatoire
dans les communes pour nous savons que
la base juridique est plus qu'incertaine
et j'utilise un euphémisme en vous
disant cela
j'ai demandé au préfet de prendre langue
avec l'ensemble des maires peu hier soir
il y en avait deux seulement qui a pris
deux arrêtés
de ce type là pour montrer que c'était à
la fois pas cohérent par rapport à
l'exigence qu'implique le confinement
parce que ça peut laisser penser qu' on
peut sortir si on a un masque en
s'affranchissant des règles du
confinement
c'est aussi un sujet qui n'est pas
médicalement démontrer vous savez les
débats qui existe sur ce sujet mais je
les dis je suis pas médecin je ne peux
pas me prononcer sur cela et donc j'ai
demandé au préfet de prendre langue avec
ses maires pour qu'ils retirent leurs
arrêtés pendant toute la période du
confinement et que nous puissions en
fonction de la doctrine nationale qui
sera mis en oeuvre pour sortir du
confinement le moment venu travailler
avec eux pour des adaptations locales si
elles apparaissent nécessaires
christophe quintana qui demandent donc
au préfet de retirer les arrêter sur le
port obligatoire du masque une réaction
jordan bardella en fait le jeu et le
problème il est bien plus simple c'est
même pas un problème juridique on est
même pas y ait ici devant un problème de
droit simplement devant un problème de
stocks devant aprem de quantité la
réalité c'est que face à la la la je
veux dire à la débâcle totale de l'état
face aux différents des injonctions
contradictoires qui ont été données ou
plus haut sommet de l'état à la
population les maires qui sont
aujourd'hui en première ligne les
acteurs locaux les élus locaux sont
obligés de s'organiser par eux mêmes et
sont obligés évidemment d'organiser des
distributions de masques quand ils en
ont la possibilité et les stocks et de
le rendre obligatoire pour casser
évidemment c'est logique de contagion
par par postillons la réalité et
monsieur castaner est bien embêté parce
que si les 36000 communes de france
décide du jour au lendemain de
d'ordonner le port du masque obligatoire
et de prendre des arrêtés pour
généraliser le port du masque
obligatoire
alors on ne pourra pas faire face pour
la simple et bonne raison qu'il n'y a
pas de stock de masques
donc on en revient toujours au même il
faut aujourd'hui se lancer dans une
économie de guerre le prix on a appliqué
dit qu'on était en guerre il a raison
nous sommes en guerre fin à un ennemi
invisible qu'elle coronavirus mais il
faut pour cela mettre en place une
économie de guerre il faut aujourd'hui
que toutes les entreprises dans le pays
que toute entreprise française qui est
en capacité aujourd'hui de réorienter sa
production pour faire des masques soit
en capacité de le faire pas seulement
les grandes boîtes pas seulement les
grands groupes il ya un certain nombre
d'initiatives ont été prises par des
entreprises partout d'enfance mais
maintenant il faut évidemment les
généraliser
il faut mettre notre économie en ordre
de guerre en ordre de bataille pour
évidemment produire massivement des
masses du matériel respiratoire du
matériel médical
tout à l'heure je l'entendais dans mon
département à saint denis un centre
cardiologique
les personnels soignants a lancé un
appel sur les réseaux sociaux a lancé un
appel sur facebook ils ont l'idée petite
pancarte à l'entrée à l'entrée du centre
en demandant à l'ensemble des habitants
du quartier qui avaient des masques à
disposition qu'il y avait des bouts de
tissus pour pouvoir concevoir et
surblouse les apportent au centre parce
que aujourd'hui il se bat sans arrêt
c'est bien là le plus dramatique
le problème n'est pas un problème de
droit c'est évidemment un problème de
munitions et et encore une fois il faut
au delà de déplorer aujourd'hui en
capacité d'agir et d'être en capacité de
mobiliser toutes les entreprises qui
peuvent évidemment problème
vous venez de mentionner votre
département de département la seine
saint denis et saint denis pardon tour
de vis ça on le sait de plusieurs
régions d'ile-de-france cinq régions à
d'ile-de-france au total interdisent
désormais la pratique du sport de 10h à
19h on sait que c'est une soupape pour
beaucoup de deux parisiens qui sont dans
des appartements petit de franciliens
mais pas en seine-saint-denis où il ya
pourtant le plus de victimes liées aux
coronavirus c'est une décision que que
vous approuvez comme vous expliquer en
tout cas mais évitez de l'aveu même du
secrétaire d'état monsieur laurent nunez
secrétaire d'état auprès de monsieur
castaner ils l'avouent eux-mêmes ils ont
fait le choix de fermer les yeux sur le
respect du confinement dans un certain
nombre de quartiers enfin je veux dire
tout le monde le dit aujourd'hui des
fonctionnaires de police le disent les
médecins le disent on a fait le choix de
fermer les yeux sur le respect du
confinement dans un certain nombre de
quartiers parce qu'on avait simplement
la crainte des émeutes
la seine-saint-denis c'est un des
départements les plus touchés de france
à l'heure où je vous parle il ya plus
une seule place en réanimation et le
taux de surmortalité de près de 63% à 2
63 % par rapport aux autres départements
donc la réalité c'est que le confinement
il s'applique à géométrie variable et
que l'unité nationale consistera aussi à
faire impliquer le confinement dans des
quartiers où pendant des années on a
baissé les bras
voilà où les médecins entrevue où la
police n'entre plus il ya un certain
d'unité police qui ont été prises à
partie compris des pompiers d'ailleurs
dans beaucoup
quartier et ce laxisme il ya des
conséquences dramatiques
pas seulement en termes sécuritaires
mais aussi aujourd'hui en terme
sanitaire parce que qui dit population à
l'expérience bien évidemment le virus
continue de se diffuser
et cela des conséquences y compris pour
ceux d'ailleurs qui respecterait le
confinement dans ces quartiers et qu'ils
sortent par exemple pour se
réapprovisionner ou faire des courses
maintenant sur la mesure dont vous
parlez n'a été prise concernant le
jogging consiste à regarder notamment
dans la ville de paris le jogging entre
10h et 19h je veux bien qu'on essaie de
moduler au niveau local un certain
nombre de restrictions
mais la conséquence elle est dramatique
parce que à 19 heures tout le monde sort
évidemment pour faire son footing et
entre 19 heures et 20 heures vous avez
trois fois plus de monde dans la rue
trois fois plus de monde qui fait son
footing et donc trois fois plus de
j'irai de de chances que le virus se
répande beaucoup plus rapidement merci
beaucoup aux jordana bardella vice
président du race version nationale
député européen d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et hier l'elysée a
donc annoncé la prolongation lieu confie
non au delà de 15 avril
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer lundi
après 20 heures pour les détails alors
que faut-il en attendre
nous sommes avec arnaud benedetti
rédacteur en chef de la revue politique
et parlementaire bonsoir arnaud
benedetti merci d'être avec nous certes
et franz le président qui s'exprimera
lundi
qu'est ce que vous en attendez vous à ce
que vous en attendez quelque chose déjà
coûté le président de la république
s'est exprimé déjà des beaucoup depuis
le début du confinement les depuis le
début de cette pandémie
ce que l'on peut attendre du président
c'est que il s'engage disons dans une
démonstration un peu plus détaillée des
mesures qu'il entend prendre dans les
semaines qui viennent à la fois sur la
poursuite du conte phonique du
confinement sur éventuellement peut-être
les mesures aussi de soutien à
l'économie qui aujourd'hui s'annonce
absolument indispensable compte tenu de
la situation d'un certain nombre de nos
tpe et pme
et puis éventuellement qu'ils engagent
des pistes sur la stratégie de
déconfinement qui sera celle disons
mises en oeuvre ou en tout cas penser
par les autorités publiques de ce pays
voilà ce qu'on peut attendre disons du
discours du président de la république
lundi prochain alors emmanuel macron qui
a décidé de consulter tous azimuts avant
de prendre ses décisions et de
s'exprimer lundi parmi ces consultations
une évidemment symbolique très remarqué
aujourd'hui celle du professeur raoul
qui est parfois controversés ça vous a
surpris les observateurs que vous êtes
cette visite à ce professeur vous savez
l'idée raul n'est pas controversé sur le
stand scientifique
oui nous fassions sa production
scientifique est une production
scientifique qui est incontestable il
publie dans les meilleures revues à
comité de lecture
il fait partie mais semblablement du top
five des meilleurs virologue au monde
d'eau que disons ça sa stature
scientifique est incontestable ce qui
est contesté en essais c'est la
méthodologie qui l'a mise en oeuvre pour
tester le traitement qu'il qu'il propose
mais en fait le président de la
république a compris que l'idée raout et
est aujourd'hui l'un des seuls voire
peut-être l'un des rares voire l'un des
seuls scientifiques qui est médecin qui
était en mesure en tout cas d'apporter
une solution certes hypothétique à la
crise que nous connaissons
et comme le président de la république
est quelqu'un qui est capable de sentir
l'opinion et il a dû certainement
consulté un certain nombre d'études
d'opinion d'ailleurs qui sont parus qui
ont montré que le traitement dû à tout
cas les solutions proposées par le
professeur out étaient des solutions qui
intéressait c'est le moins que le puisse
dire
une large partie de nos de nos
concitoyens il a compris que cette ce
déplacement à marseille était important
d'autant plus qu'il faut le rappeler
qu'un certain nombre d'élus
je pense au maire de nice je pense au
président de la région paca
je pense au président de l'exécutif
corse gilles simeoni ou et où l ancien
ministre de la santé comme philippe
douste-blazy appel à une généralisation
de ceux de ce traitement donc dans un
contexte qu'il veut être celui lui était
nationale il est important que le
président de la république envoie des
des signes adressent des messages à une
partie des grands élus et une partie de
l'opinion publique gsk nommé des tilles
les français n'attendent pas davantage
aussi de clarté on cette quatrième
semaine de confinement strict notamment
sur la question des tests des masques
aussi avoir peut-être des encouragements
sur une stratégie de déconfinement alors
que je le répète à nos voisins européens
eux commencent à parler de déconfinement
nous eh bien c'est l'omerta comment vous
vous l'expliquer non c'est pas tout à
fait le merten parce que le collet
ministre avait dix ont déjà parlé en
tout cas évoqué un certain nombre de
pistes possibles devant les
parlementaires sur la stratégie de
déconfinement et il lui a été reproché
d'ailleurs au demeurant d'en avoir parlé
vraisemblablement trop tôt en effet ce
qu'attendent aujourd'hui une partie de
nos compatriotes c'est des réponses
précises et pratiques sur les manques
sanitaires qui sont ceux aujourd'hui du
pays et que la crise a cruellement
illustré c'est à dire la question du
masque l'utilité ou non du masque la
question des tests
c'est parfaitement liée au dés
confinement totalement mais également la
question de la chloroquine qui se posent
des stands de chloroquine donc on voit
bien que sur l'ensemble de ces de ses
segments très pratique jusqu'à présent
le président de république et l'exécutif
n'ont pas été en mesure d'apporter des
réponses précises tout simplement parce
que d'abord il ne sont vraisemblablement
pas tous d'accord sur une stratégie
disons de déconfinement en tout cas sur
les moyens d'opérer cette stratégie de
déconfinement et puis ensuite parce que
nous avons deux cruellement que sur le
plan sanitaire que la communication
d'ailleurs chaotique de l'exécutif n'a
pas été en mesure de dissimuler ses
moins qu'on puisse dire merci beaucoup à
nos benedetti d'avoir été avec mon
directeur tesfran ce rédacteur en chef
de la revue politique et parlementaire
les tests de dépistage justement bien en
parler un très utilisé même nécessaire
pour freiner la propagation du corona
virus mais problème la france on manque
cruellement elles ont produit pas assez
les laboratoires en sont conscients et
se mobilisent comme à
saint-amand-les-eaux adam département du
nord un reportage signé caroline berg et
un robin pu l
depuis lundi les véhicules se succèdent
sur le parking du complexe sportif de
saint-amand-les-eaux
le laboratoire de biologie médicale y a
installé son drive pour effectuer les
tests de dépistage du coronavirus ouvert
seulement le matin une cinquantaine de
tests ont déjà été effectués une
procédure organisée avec l'aide de la
municipalité pour mieux répondre à la
demande des patients et du personnel de
santé
c'était vraiment une demande d'ailleurs
de nos confrères prospector de nos
collègues infirmières de pouvoir
répondre à leur demande de pouvoir
profiter les façons on a su dès qu'on a
pu le faire dont on a mis ça en place
et parce que je pense vraiment que ça
répondait à une demande de leur part
sont le plan organisation pour les
passants se parlent beaucoup plus simple
de pouvoir se faire dépister sur leur
lieu de résidence à saint-amand que
devoir aller sur un site lillois ou
valenciennois mais ici ils se sont
finalement saison ces tests ne peuvent
s'effectuer que sur prescription
médicale
ils sont réservés aux patients désigné
c'est à dire présentant les symptômes du
coffee 19 plusieurs personnes à risque
ont pu ainsi se faire dépister
mais aussi des membres du personnel
hospitalier en première ligne face au
virus pouvoir être fixé sur son état de
santé étant soulagement pour certains
d'entre eux je sais que j'ai des
collègues qui sont allés aux urnes ans
qui n'ont pas été dépisté qu'ils ont été
entre guillemets diagnostiqué covin mais
qui n'ont pas été dépistées pour pour ça
moi j'ai la chance mon médecin entre
guillemets m'a demandé le dépistage mais
sinon à l'hôpital nom n'est pas dépistée
systématiquement avec gilles avantage
d'être persona donc je peux pas c'est
est donc c'est rassurant pour moi aussi
je veux dire c'est ça ou c'est pas ça et
puis en même temps c'est pour préserver
aussi mon entourage le laboratoire de
biologie médicale pourrait également
être opérationnel dans les prochains
jours afin d'assurer les tests
sérologiques une anticipation en vue de
répondre au mieux aux futures décisions
du gouvernement pour organiser la sortie
du confinement
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
parleront des violences domestiques et
conjugales qui ont fortement augmenté en
france depuis le début du confinement
comment garder le lien avec les victimes
nous partirons suite aux états unis qui
en régissent pour la deuxième journée
consécutive près de 2000 morts liés aux
comics 19
et puis direction le brésil où les
peuples autochtones sont à la merci à
eux aussi du virus hcv
[Musique]
si on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
le numérique ça et mais aujourd'hui 4 %
des gaz à effet de serre dans le monde
tous les citoyens qui utilisent par
exemple des ordinateurs polluent la
planète
à chaque fois qu'on a une requête
internet on envoie un email
qu'on l'ait qu'une photo sur instagram
ça en impact carbone un email envoyé
avec une pièce jointe
c'est l'équivalent d'une ampoule allumée
pendant une heure comme celle ci
peu de gens ont conscience que le
numérique pollue pire encore ils pensent
que le numérique est un outil qui
permettrait de réduire la consommation
d'énergie le numérique est en quelque
sorte un pharmaco en pharma concept un
mot grec ancien qui veut dire à être à
la fois remède est poison c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'il faut utiliser
avec
avec sagesse avec mesure c'est ce qui
fera le plus de bien à la planète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû revenir
les systèmes de plis heureux parce que
cela permet de développer de très
grandes surfaces à l'intérieur de tout
petits espaces ce n'est donc pas
surprenant de voir de l'origami dans les
selles d'insectes et dans les feuilles
dans l'intestin
on peut même voir des systèmes depuis
elle semblable sur le cortex les objets
inspirés par les origamis surgissent
déjà dans notre quotidien
comment imaginer que le pliage d'une
simple surfaces planes nous porte vers
la découverte d'un code universel de la
nature
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
nous sommes avec philippe douste blazy
ancien médecin ministre de la santé sous
la présidence de jacques chirac
est-ce que vous ne portez pas une part
de responsabilité comme tous les
ministres de la santé de moi je fais
partie des gens extrêmement humble et
qui pensent que bien évidemment j'aurais
eu tout faire depuis le premier jour de
ma vie mieux quand on voit la gestion de
cette crise est une gestion d'urgence le
constat est plutôt catastrophique pour
un pays comme la france
lorsqu'on est dans une guerre ne
reconnaît au front il y était question
qu'on peut se poser
il ya des questions que se posera plus
tard parce que c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire quand on n'en voit jamais
personne n'aurait pu penser que nous
serions aujourd'hui nouveau je vous
parle en saturation des lits de
réanimation en seine saint denis a quasi
saturation sur l'île de france
la seule chose qui peut compter
maintenant c'est le confinement le
dépistage l'entraînement et j'espère que
tu confinement sera remarquablement fait
parce que là la différence en
confinement moyennement fait et un
confinement très bien fait c'est des
centaines de l'hydre et à la salle
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre 20h30 heure
française en direct sur rt france
restez chez vous c'est donc le mot
d'ordre vous le savez maintenant depuis
le 17 mars mais dans certains foyers
le confinement tourne parfois au
cauchemar les autorités constatent une
hausse très importante des signalements
de violences conjugales notamment
jusqu'à 36 % d'augmentation en une
semaine pour l'ile-de-france uniquement
dans l'hexagone comme ailleurs
gouvernement ces associations tentent de
venir en aide aux victimes les
explications en images
[Musique]
les violences conjugales partout dans le
monde vous l'avez vu mais aussi violence
sur les enfants elle explose depuis le
début du confinement
la ligne téléphonique dédiée en france a
reçu 20 % d'appels supplémentaires c'est
ce qu'a annoncé aujourd'hui le
secrétaire d'état à la protection de
l'enfance
les appels considéré comme urgent même
augmenté de 60 % si l'on compare les
trois premières semaines du confinement
à une période équivalente
or confinement et pour en parler
de ces violences nous sommes en direct
avec catherine verdier psychologue
thérapeute analystes pour enfants et
adolescents fondatrice de psy famille
bonsoir kathryn huberty merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on va
essayer de scinder les problèmes 1 avant
d'évoquer la violence sur les enfants un
mot sur ces violences conjugales qui ont
explosé partout dans le monde et en
france notamment
on dit souvent une période de
confinement a sauvé une vie tous les 8
minutes c'est donc un paradoxe terrible
est ce que vous vous craignez un bilan
lourd beaucoup de victimes
oui le bilan il risque d'être lourd
effectivement ce confinement il implique
un manque d espace physique et un angle
despatie chic c'est à dire qu'on est les
uns sur les autres 24 heures sur 24 et
on va parler des enfants probablement
mais les parents sont également parents
24 heures sur 24 et ce en vacances sans
aucune vacance pour le moment d'annoncer
alors malheureusement cet état un
constat prévisible ou n'est pas étonné
j'imagine non c'est non c'est passé
absolument pas étonnant du tout pas du
tout puisque de toute façon quand tout
le monde j'aurais peut-être quand tout
le monde est sous le même toit et qui a
pas de moyen de s'échapper de son de son
agresseur de son bureau de son bourreau
par 37 1 a reçu ce quand on a pas moyen
d'aller respirer ou de respirer de
respirer ailleurs de ceux de voir
d'autres gens aussi
c'est très très important effectivement
les violences il ya des violences en
fait par rapport aux enfants en tout cas
il ya des violences
les enfants qui sont qui ont été ou qui
sont mal traités depuis un certain temps
et puis il ya ces nouvelles violences
moi j'appelle ça la violence fille nés
quelque part et ces nouvelles violences
qui qui émane de parents qui n'en
peuvent plus et qui sont qui sont
complètement complètement débordé je
crois justement est ce que les autorités
en font assez à part nous dire
effectivement qu'il faut respecter ce
confinement est ce que toutes ces
problématiques notamment dans les
familles dysfonctionnelles est-ce qu'ils
sont suffisamment pris
en compte aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement ça c'est sûr que par
exemple les familles où les enfants sont
autistes
tout simplement pour ne prendre que ce
cas là c'est un le confinement était
extrêmement compliqué à gérer pour pour
les parents et pour les enfants bien sûr
vous avez tous les enfants qui sont
j'aime pas mettre des étiquettes mais
qui sont un peu hyperactif et qui ont
besoin de bouger énormément items c'est
c'est compliqué de trouver des
alternatives pour parvenir à les allées
faire bouger correctement et à les
canaliser pour que pour que tout le
monde puisse arriver à vivre en bonne
harmonie et pourtant justement vous
parliez d'enfants hyperactifs pas
confondre avec des autistes pour qui je
crois il ya une certaine disposition
voilà on autorise les parents peut-être
avec des enfants autistes à davantage
sortir mais les impératifs ce qu'on
appelle les tdh c'est pas du tout le cas
justement comment on explique voilà ce
moment que pas de considération c'est
pas le mot parce que ça serait un
jugement de valeur mais en tout cas le
fait que ces phénomènes n'est pas été
correctement pris en compte par les
autorités aujourd'hui dans le cadre de
ce confinement
je crois très très franchement je crois
qu'on est dans une situation
complètement inédite et que tout le
monde n'a pas pensé à tout on a pensé
scolaire comme toujours on a pensé on a
pensé aux épreuves aux airs aux épreuves
de bac on a pensé aux apprentissages
qu'il fallait absolument suivre mais
tout ce qui est santé mentale on n'y a
pas pensé je ne crois pas en tout cas
pas suffisamment
effectivement pour ses enfants pour tous
ces enfants qui ont besoin mais tous les
enfants de toute façon besoin de jouer
et ont besoin d'air mais c'est vrai
qu'il y en a certains qui en ont un peu
plus besoin que d'autres
je crois qu'effectivement il n'y a pas
grand chose qui a été fait pour eux que
ce soit les violences conjugales ou la
maltraitance des enfants des choses ont
quand même été mise en place le sms 114
le fait de pouvoir aller dans des
pharmacies expliqué voilà ces problèmes
le fait de pouvoir aller porter plainte
on nous dit mme adams qui a pas est-ce
que c'est c'est suffisant selon vous
parce que c'est encore pire quand on
rentre à la maison on peut peut-être
aller porter plainte mais enfin le
retour à la maison ne doit pas être
aisée ce que ces femmes là notamment
sont suffisamment protégés je vous
poserai certainement la même question
concernant les enfants elles ne sont
déjà pas assez en temps entre guillemets
normal donc effectivement dans une
situation pareille elles ne le sont
quasiment pas papa tu pas du tout quoi
elles sont là avec leurs bourreaux à
tourner en rond et a essayé d'esquiver
ce qu'elles peuvent esquiver quoi mais
c'est c'est c'est terrible franchement
excusez-moi jambes et game et c'est
vraiment terrible de se retrouver dans
une situation qu'on les fasse à son bord
ou quoi ou à son agresseur donc il ya
ces femmes là et puis il ya aussi je
crois qu'on n'en fait pas assez pour ses
agresseurs finalement ils ont aussi
besoin d'être aidés ils sont les
premiers à être à devoir être aidés et à
leur proposer des plateformes pour
qu'ils puissent discuter ou pour qu'ils
puissent être prises en charge tout
simplement ses hommes ce sont des sommes
bien évidemment et c'est c'est n'y a pas
grand chose non plus qu'il soit fait
pour eux aujourd'hui ça sera ma dernière
question est ce qu'il ya des plateformes
qui sont mis en place justement pour les
gens qui craquent que ce soient les
victimes et vous l'avez dit aussi les
bourreaux peut-être voir des possibilité
d'entretenir des
des séances avec des psys peut-être à
distance vpn
oui tout à fait les psys sont très très
très mobilisé il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
plateformes qui s'organise
et puis vous pouvez en retrouver des
plus grandes plateformes sur l'unicef
sur le 119 sur sur d'autres plateformes
comme ça mais il ya pas mal de psy qui
s'organisent en groupes un regroupement
et qui propose des prises en charge et
dz totalement gratuite d'ailleurs par
par skype ou par visioconférence ou par
ou même simplement par téléphone oui il
ya beaucoup de beaucoup de choses
d'initiatives personnelles et locales il
faut pas hésiter à aller se renseigner
auprès de la pharmacie en particulier
auprès de votre pharmacie qui est pas
loin auprès de votre médecin normalement
ils doivent être informés
on espère que ces victimes nous
entendrons en tout cas merci catherine
verdier d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur r c'est mon france dans l'actualité
également donc le coronavirus dont le
monde aux états unis
ces chiffres qui montrent l'ampleur de
la pandémie outre atlantique il ya plus
de 430 mille cas confirmés c'est plus
que dans n'importe quel autre pays sur
la planète
quinze mille morts au total et ce bilan
meurtrier quotidien très lourd 2000
morts en 24 heures et c'est dans ce
contexte de crise sanitaire que bernie
sanders en course pour l'investiture
démocrate en vue de l'élection
présidentielle a mis un terme hier à sa
campagne
la campagne se termine la lutte continue
peut-on lire dans le communiqué publié
par le candidat socialiste et donc joe
biden son adversaire qui devrait
affronter en novembre donal trump
peuvent c'est la deuxième fois de sa
carrière que bernie sanders laisse la
voie libre à son adversaire
retour en images sur un an de campagne
acharnée
[Musique]
et
il
le
[Musique]
en fait
et pour parler de cette course à la
présidentielle en pleine crise sanitaire
nous sommes avec ericsson mon brodé
républicaine thing france
bonsoir rx fans merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france c'est vrai
qu'avec un masque c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on ne parle que de cette
crise du bus oui sauf si vous êtes à
proximité de plein d'autres personnes on
voudrait pas voilà vous empêcher de vous
exprimer en va en tout cas c'est quand
même un coup de tonnerre dans cette dans
cette campagne présidentielle même si
aujourd'hui on le sait en france comme
aux états unis
cette crise du coronavirus balaye tout
bernie sanders qui jette donc l'épongé
votre réaction vous étiez surpris vous
n'ont pas du tout les démocrates ne
veulent pas d'un socialiste par mieux et
je dirais dieu merci
prions au seigneur qui lie qu'il ait
fait cela parce que en personne ne veut
les américains ne veulent pas devenir
comme le venezuela
et puis le reste du monde n'a pas besoin
que l'amérique de queuleu la locomotive
économique du monde devienne comme le
venezuela
alors pourquoi at il abandonné selon
vous il est il est pour moi d'abord je
dirais je suis même pas certain que ces
biden qui sera le candidat
ça m'étonnerait pas que ce soit
couramment en plus gourmands le merde le
gouverneur de new york de l'état du new
york qui va prendre le relais et je
dirais que c'est
ils attendent que qu'une seule grande
bourde de bime donc ils vous disent que
que les démocrates disent non on va on
va faire un un coup comme ils ont fait
en 2016
aujourd'hui avec ce thème comment se
passe cette campagne présidentielle
parce que c'est vrai que là on prend
quelques minutes pour pour en parler
parce que c'est important mais
évidemment quand on parle de la mort de
milliers de personnes ça balaye tout
donc comment se passe-t-elle ce que les
américains s'y intéressent malgré tout
bien sûr qu'il fait intéressant je crois
que les gens ne comprennent pas ni les
américains ni surtout les européennes ne
comprennent pas là la mentalité de 2
dans l'antre sommes dans cette histoire
pourquoi il paraît tous les jours
il veut il est certain qu'il veut
apparaître comme celui qui est qui
comprend les problèmes mais je crois que
c'est le vrai que je crois pas que c'est
du diable il veut apparaître comme la
personne qui qui commet qui comprend les
problèmes et qui va et s'y résoudra et
la trouver des solutions avec l'aide du
corps médical
justement les américains semblent assez
clément vous avez pas le démentir
m'enfin donald trump a eu une attitude
très distantes 1 par rapport à cette
crise du coronavirus au départ on s'en
souvient il et même un petit peu ironisé
aujourd'hui le bilan des états unis
et bien pire que que celui voilà on les
autres pays ça devient l'épicentre de de
cette épidémie
vous restez vous en défense de donald
trump
je respire en défense je reste jamais en
défense de donald trump georges bush
ouvrant la vraie gamme je reste toujours
en défense de la réalité
l'autre réalité qu'on nous dit qu on
oublie trop vite c'est que les états
unis ont été le premier pays à la trump
a été le premier à bannir les vols
depuis la chine et à l'époque évidemment
c'était une raison de plus pour quel
qu'il soit ap les lots somme est raciste
et soudain cinq semaines après 4 5
semaines après les européens nous ont en
fait de même et soudain ce n'était plus
raciste du tout ce n'était pas un
républicain ne fait un conservateur que
c est ce que c'est raciste
et n'oublions pas aussi que l'amérique
c'est 300 millions de personnes la spse
330 millions de francs à deux personnes
comment la france et 65 millions je
pense l'italie 70 millions il faut c'est
plein de chiffres qu'on ne prend pas en
considération
je sais pas si vous savez pourquoi une
statistique c'est comme un but unique
selon george fisher et bien c'est parce
qu'une statistique ça des voix le plein
de choses mais ça cache l'essentiel est
qu'on nous parle de l'espagne et a
dépassé les mille morts
c'est vrai c'est pas assez il faut faire
attention mais / 45 millions c'est la
fée 0,005 % des morts telle est la
population espagnole qui est morte et
une autre chose qu'il faut dire c'est
pourquoi on me dit toujours oui 100
milliards huit cent vingt ans en italie
depuis une semaine un jour depuis 24
heures pourquoi ne nous partagerons
pourquoi n'utilise ton pas cela en
tranches d'âge je dirais que la raison
c'est parce qu'on veut pas dire que la
grande majorité des des morts ce sont
des gens âgés alors il ya un seul pays
que j'ai trouvé où j'ai trouvé que les
gens avaient avaient trouvé ces
informations dresser nos vieux amis les
israéliens alors selon le jerusalem post
je vous lire juste une phrase ou deux la
plupart des morts du commandant vario
des ruches ont été dédommagés avec
d'autres maladies en plus 64 pour cent
des morts sont des hommes seulement six
pour cent des morts sont au moins de 60
ans et l'âge moyen des morts en israël
c'est 79 en verre du wit
il faut quand même prendre ça en
considération aussi
non il ya beaucoup d'études comme ça
avec deux effectivement ces mêmes
statistiques on peut lire en france ça
il ya aucun souci mais vous avez raison
quand même de son millier de voix là de
nous apporter un autre point de vue on
est là pour ça les etats unis sont un
plus grand pays il n'empêche les
stratégies de confinement strict que
nous avons apportées adoptées en europe
ne sont pas forcément adoptée aux états
unis est ce que c'est c'est quoi c'est
une culture très libérale tout
simplement c'est pas dans la culture
américaine c'est un choix assumé
n'oublions pas que les états unis ne
sont pas un pays comme la france ou
l'italie
c'est une union un peu comme l'union
européenne et que chaque état à des à
des réactions différentes et que comme
en france sont les états le plus à
gauche c'est à dire new york et
californie qui sont aussi les états les
plus comment dire les plus urbanisées
qui font le plus de le plus de vous
voyez on voit new york en ce moment
times square ceux qui font le plus de
choses atroces deux semaines trois
semaines la ville triste gamme qui est
ainsi admis ce qui était en bikini sur
la plage de nice elle était considérée
horrible parce qu'il était serein sur
cette plage rocailleuse mais il y avait
personne d'autre en californie à malibu
c'est la même chose
un ticket sur son surf bord de l'un avec
la pagaie et il
il commet dit il il est à des kilomètres
de qui que ce soit il se fait arrêter et
la seule fois où il est en contact
direct et personnes soit être les
policiers sur le bateau et la station
commissariat donc ça devient un peu fou
je dirais comme disait votre celtic qui
avec qui vous avez parlé avant des
adultes ont besoin de jouer aussi
catherine verdier notre la psychologue
pour les avons invités
merci beaucoup en tout cas ericsson
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et l'organisation mondiale de la
santé qui appelle à ne pas politiser le
virus on se retrouve au coeur de
tensions diplomatiques
donald trump l'a vivement critiqué
menaçant même de suspendre le
financement des états unis les
précisions de grégoire douce et la passe
d'armes se poursuit dès mardi les
critiques du président américain se sont
abattues sur l' oms
évoquant une gestion de crise qui ne
seraient pas à la hauteur des corps de
gros ils se sont trompés ils auraient pu
avertir quelques mois plus tôt il aurait
su nikko cordial et ils auraient dû le
savoir ils le savaient probablement des
world
donc nous allons examiner cela très
attentivement et nous allons mettre un
frein au fond des points 6 pour l' oms
nous allons mettre un frein très
puissant à ses dépenses et nous allons
voir à nouveau dénoncé la réaction du
directeur général de l' oms ne s'est pas
fait attendre
dès le lendemain tedros adhanom gay
briguer sousse a appelé les acteurs
politiques à prendre de la hauteur et à
s'unir pour gérer l'urgence de la crise
tous les acteurs politiques devraient se
concentrer sur le fait de sauver des
vies au sein de leur population
s'il vous plaît il ne faut pas politiser
ce virus j'en appelle à une solidarité
honnête au niveau mondial et un
leadership honnête des états unis et de
la chine d ios engine comme pendant la
guerre froide nous avons moins de
problèmes que pendant la guerre froide
ceux qui ont des vues différentes
devraient unir leurs forces pour
combattre la pandémie
pour le locataire de la maison blanche
lorsque tedros adhanom gay briller sous
appelle à ne pas politiser
virus il produit l'effet inverse quand
il dit politisé ils politisent cela ne
devrait pas être le cas
mais écoutez nous avons dépensé 450
milliards de dollars 452 milliards de
dollars des centaines de milliards au
cours des années précédentes
il doit faire mieux que cela il doit
faire mieux
quand vous parlez de politique je ne
peux pas croire qu'elle parle de
politique
quand vous regardez la relation client
avec la chine si donald trump accuse
l'organisation onusienne de complaisance
envers la chine
l' oms a en parallèle reçu des soutiens
c'est le cas du président français
emmanuel macron qui a réaffirmé sa
confiance dans l'institution sanitaire
antonio guterres est ce le secrétaire
général de l'onu appelle lui à l'unité
et à la solidarité pour arrêter ce virus
et inquiétudes autour des peuples
autochtones au brésil d'après
international organisation consacrée à
la défense de ces peuples deux qu'un de
kobe de 10,9 dont un mortel ont été
confirmés parmi ces populations dans le
monde entier plusieurs communautés
autochtones prennent des mesures
d'isolement pour se protéger contre le
virus on écoute l'analyse de sarah
chalke ailleurs chargé de campagne à
survival international
[Musique]
des coronavirus est une menace réelle
pour les populations indigènes du monde
entier et en particulier pour les tribus
isolées qui sont les plus vulnérables de
la planète et qui reste très peu aux
maladies extérieures solo ou leurs
terres sont protégés ces tribus sont
l'un des peuples le plus en sécurité de
la planète à l'heure actuelle mais là où
leurs terres sont envahis et où il ya
des bouchons et des mineurs illégaux
mais aussi d'autres envahisseurs et
légaux y compris des missionnaires dans
ce cas les tribus sont particulièrement
à risque et le coronavirus pourrait
anéantir toute leur population tic
il ya de nombreux territoires indigènes
au brésil où les invasions illégales ont
explosé depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir du
président bolcho darroze
il a encouragé les invasions des terres
indigènes et il veut qu'elle soit
utilisée pour l'agro business afin
d'être volé il encourage également
l'exploitation minière il a donc
encouragé les envahisseurs nous l'avons
vu dans tout le pays y compris par
exemple sur les terres du peuple
yanomami
parmi ces indigènes certains ont des
contacts avec la société mais d'autres
non ces derniers sont particulièrement
vulnérables
[Musique]
les yanomami on signalait qu'il pourrait
y avoir jusqu'à 20000 envahisseurs
illégaux sur le territoire en ce moment
même de même le peuple kaua'i va sans
contact avec la société dans l'ouest du
brésil a déclaré que beaucoup
d'envahisseurs essayer de rentrer dans
leur territoire les awa du nord-est du
brésil et de l'amazone y ont eux aussi
repérer des envahisseurs dans cette
région et ses envahisseurs s'ils sont
porteurs du chronobus
cela pourrait être fatal pour les tribus
isolées bien sûr le corona virus est un
problème pour nous tous mais les peuples
indigènes y compris les tribus isolées
sont dans une catégorie différente dans
de nombreux cas ils sont
géographiquement très éloignés des
hôpitaux graphique les tailles et mme
manigat
lorsque nous parlons dans des gènes qui
ont des contacts avec la société
le problème pour eux et que leur mode de
vie communautaire pourrait encourager la
propagation du virus
bien qu'il prenne des précautions pour
s'isoler même des autres familles au
sein de leur communauté et qu'ils
prennent des précautions pour se mettre
en quarantaine dans la forêt mais il ya
toujours un risque que le virus puisse
les attentes en ce qui concerne les
populations indigènes qui ont des
contacts avec la société
dans de nombreux cas y compris au brésil
il n'existe pas de système adéquat pour
s'occuper d'elle au brésil les
populations indigènes de tout le pays
réclame une amélioration du système de
santé ars collègues aux années
le président bolle sonar ou avec la
guerre qu'il a mené contre les indigènes
et son racisme à leur égard a également
réduit de manière drastique les systèmes
de santé dont ils disposaient cela
signifie qu'il se trouve dans une
situation très difficile à l'heure
actuelle ils font actuellement pression
et proteste avec beaucoup d'énergie pour
que le gouvernement garantisse une
réponse adéquate aux gros navires us
pour les populations indigènes a
response
je pense que cela a ouvert les yeux du
monde entier et que les gens ont encore
réalisé s'il ne l'avait pas déjà fait le
danger des nouvelles maladies pour les
tribus isolées c'est un danger constant
non seulement avec le coronavirus mais
avec n'importe quelle autre maladie même
un simple rhume ou une grippe pourrait
les réduire à néant
waxman nous encourageons donc nos
partisans du monde entier à s'impliquer
dans la campagne pour faire pression sur
les gouvernements afin de s'assurer que
les terres des pubs l'isoler soient
protégés ou qu'elle puisse survivre
s'épanouir et vivre de la manière
qu'elle choisisse sans coronavirus une
toute autre menace extérieure
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la situation des
prisons françaises face au collet
russe qui compte huit mille détenus en
moins et puis nous parlerons de la
réunion de l'opep qui tombe de trouver
un équilibre sur le marché du pétrole ce
sera enfin l'édito échos de jacques
sapir qui tentera de répondre à cette
question que peut-on encore attentes de
l'union européenne et de ses
institutions dans cette crise
[Musique]
la prévision pib sont très inférieurs à
ce qu'on avait au départ elle s'aggrave
est ce que finalement les gouvernements
ne sont pas en train de prendre
conscience de la gravité qui les attend
les prévisions de monsieur le maire sauf
une grotesque les unes que les autres
n'y a pas un gouvernement aujourd'hui il
n'ya pas évidemment un analyste le banc
qui s'est exactement se peut ce pour
battre honte sur la tête
en france il ya en europe d'ailleurs les
bandes sont au plus mal
aujourd'hui je pense que tous les
banquiers se se couchent le soir
en croisant les doigts qui est pas bonne
comme la main dites vous bien que 2008
c'était une crisette ça n'a strictement
rien à voir on est dans quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas connue depuis des siècles
et des siècles
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui compte on soit
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui une gauche l'extrême tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande île interview nous allons évoquer
ici des sujets stratégiques pour notre
pays et sur ces dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants dieu la
première erreur de notes administration
a été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient la résultante de 15 ans
de travail de fond fait par les
allemands eon clair ils ont prêché la
guerre sainte et le problème c'est qu'on
les a trop longtemps les équipes il ya
eu un espèce de déni de réalité et il a
fallu le drap
l'attaquant pour qu'il y ait enfin une
reconnaissance générale de la situation
dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice madame bello
bay annonce la sortie en 2020 de 40 3 du
à 10 140 avant fin 2022 sur les 531
incarcéré aujourd'hui l'équipe croit que
la majeure partie de ces individus mus
par la haine de la france est désormais
libre de son pain défi pour la sécurité
nationale avec philippe douste blazy
ancien médecin ministre de la santé sous
la présidence de jacques chirac
est-ce que vous ne portez pas une part
de responsabilité comme tous les
ministres de la santé dont je fais
partie des gens extrêmement humble et
qui pensent que bien évidemment j'aurais
eu tous heures depuis le premier jour de
ma vie mieux quand on voit la gestion de
cette crise et une gestion d'urgence le
constat est plutôt catastrophique pour
un pays comme la france
lorsqu'on est dans une guerre lorsqu'on
est au front il ya des questions pour
proposer il ya des questions qui
s'opposera plus tard parce que c'est une
catastrophe sanitaire comme on n'en voit
jamais personne n'aurait pu penser que
nous serions aujourd'hui moment où je
vous parle en saturation des lits de
réanimation en seine saint denis a quasi
saturation sur l'île de france
la seule chose qui peut compter
maintenant c'est le confinement le
dépistage notre étonnement et j'espère
que ce confinement sera remarquablement
fait parce que là la différence en
confinement moyennement c est un
confinement très bien fait c'est des
centaines de lits drea à l'ensemble
[Musique]
21h heure française merci de nous
rejoindre pour cette demi heure
d'information tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi
la france passe la barre des 12 milles
morts liés aux coronavirus et compte 4
124 nouveaux décès en 24 heures annonce
du directeur général de la santé alors
que les français restent dans
l'incertitude en cette quatrième semaine
de confinement le président doit
s'exprimer lundi il a rencontré cet
après midi à marseille le professeur
parfois controversés didier rahout face
à la crise la france relève son temps
d'urgence à 100 milliards d'euros
la conférence élargie entre pays
producteurs de pétrole elle est cruciale
pour tenter de trouver un équilibre
alors que la demande d'or noir devrait
chuter en 2020 était plus arrivé depuis
2009 l'opep et ses dix partenaires vont
essayer de s'accorder sur des baisses de
production afin de soutenir les prix qui
ne se sont effondrées avec la pandémie
[Musique]
l'europe a divisés sur la réponse
économique à la crise du coronavirus les
ministres des finances de la zone euro
continue de diviser sur les moyens à
mettre en oeuvre face à la récession qui
s'annonce la pire depuis 1945
retour au mécanisme européen de
stabilité corona manceau cliquant une
mutualisation des dettes les blocages
sont nombreux alors que peut-on attendre
de lui et de ses institutions dans cette
crise c'est à cette question tentera
répondent l'économiste jacques sapir à
21h15
la france totalise donc 12210 décès liés
aux coronavirus 424 nouveaux décès
enregistrés dans les dernières 24 heures
dont les hôpitaux annonce il y à
quelques minutes de jérôme c'est domont
directeur général de la santé
quatre-vingt deux patients en moins en
réanimation ce jeudi pour les bonnes
nouvelles au total plus de 23000
personnes sont sortis guéris de
l'hôpital 2002 plus aujourd'hui demain
de nouveaux tgv médicalisé transféreront
des patients de l'île de france vers la
nouvelle aquitaine et les mesures de
confinement sont en place en france
depuis maintenant le 17 mars
alors si tout le monde a dû s'organiser
pour s'adapter
des décisions ont été aussi prises pour
préserver les détenus incarcérés dans
les prisons du pays
les décisions qui ont parfois vu naître
des mutineries des précisions sur la
situation dans les prisons en images
[Musique]
mo
et pour évoquer ces prisons françaises
face au virus nous sommes en direct avec
lui à qui mme guyot député ps de la
première circonscription de l'orne
ancien directeur de la prison de fresnes
bonsoir ya qui ont payé au merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on a
évoqué évidemment début d'émeute auront
début de confinement quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui dans les prisons
est ce qu'elle s'est améliorée
je pense que les détenus comprennent
l'intérêt de d'impliquer confinement y
compris dans les établissements
pénitentiaires alors c'est sûr que les
établissements peuvent être en tension
notamment dans les maisons d'arrêt il ya
encore une surpopulation
lorsque les détenus soient plusieurs une
cellule il est bien évident que
confinement est plus difficile à
supporter que lorsqu'un détenu est seul
en cellule et c'est le cas de la plupart
des maisons d'arrêt alors effectivement
le garde des sceaux par ordonnance a
pris des décisions notamment ne pas
exécuter des courtes peines libérer
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont moins
de deux mois de détention à effectuer et
puis également libérer les détention
provisoire dans l'attenté du jugement
puis finalement il ya une activité
judiciaire qui est en diminution ce qui
fait que actuellement les prisons sont
moins peuplées huit mille détenus en
moins et nous sommes sur un taux
d'occupation absence en 203 4 % c'est
vrai que c'est mieux en terme de deux de
tension mais quand vous supprimez
effectivement les activités en prison
c'est compliqué aussi bien pour les
personnels que pour que pour les détenus
mais je crois qu'il faut protéger les
personnels pénitentiaires et c'est vrai
qu'ils ont il a fallu également qu'on
demande à ce que les personnels soient
mieux protégés dans leur mission de tous
les jours et puis également pour les
détenus qui sont suspectés d'avoir
effectivement attrapé ce virus avait
également de les mettre à l'isolément
total avec de la protection égale ment
voilà ça c'est un sujet qui est majeure
si on veut pas effectivement que le coc
vie de 19 se développe se développe dans
les établissements pénitentiaires
alors justement un surveillant est
décédé du commis de
19 afrique deux détenus comment éviter
cette propagation qui semble pourtant
inéluctable selon nous alors moi je suis
pas médecin mais je pense qu'il faut
absolument que tous les agents soient
équipés de matériel de protection comme
on le fait actuellement
dans certains établissements qui héberge
des personnes et je crois qu'il faut
absolument que saccageant et des masques
alors quand aux détenus bien si on peut
effectivement les deux thés également de
masques qui sortent leur cellule par
exemple ou lorsque ils ont une activité
pas collective mais lorsqu'il les
détenus vont en cours de promenade
c'est également un moment délicat dans
dans la détention donc je crois qu'il
faut renforcer toutes les mesures pour
protéger à la fois des personnels et par
conséquent également les détenus pour
faire face à cette situation vous l'avez
dit 1,8 mille détenus ont été ont été
libérés il ya moins de 1000 détenus en
moins dans les prisons françaises
faut-il s'en inquiéter
selon vous c'est une décision qui a été
critiquée par certains
oui je voulais le problème c'est quand
même notre surpopulation pénale si et on
avait suffisamment de prison en france
est suffisamment de place chez ces
décisions auraient pas été opportune bon
moi je pense que compte tenu de la
conjoncture actuelle
je pense que le garde des sceaux a bien
fait voilà mais il faut regarder tous
les détenus qui sont qui ont été libérés
les moines de moi il faut vérifier à ce
qu'il n'y ait pas eu des détenus
condamnés pour des faits de violence
pour des faits terroristes
effectivement cette cité située à
regarder et tous les phénomènes de
violence donc je pense que si c'est des
détenus qui sont en fin de peine et qui
ont eu par exemple un bon comportement
et qu'ils ont commis des délits qui met
pas forcément en jeu leur public
eh bien je pense que on prend moins de
risques et donc je crois que c'est en
matière de de mesurer les risques qu'il
faut qu'il faut raisonner
je pense que le garde des sceaux a bien
fait de prendre les dispositions
qu'elle vienne arrêté il ya quelques
quelques semaines voilà je crois que
c'est plutôt dans cet effet avec
beaucoup de réflexion ce n'est pas
simple mais je crois qu'il fallait quand
même le faire alors la droite a
néanmoins vertement critiqué cette
décision le rn sans surprise également
eric ciotti selon lui 130 détenus
radicaliser son dehors ce que dément
d'ailleurs nicole belloubet qui dit vrai
ce que vous vous avez par hasard la
réponse non je n'ai pas la réponse mais
je ne bois pas franchement un
établissement ou un magistrat libérés
avant sa fin de peine
un détenu qui a été impliqué dans une
affaire de terrorisme alors c'est je ne
comprends pas donc je crois que c'est il
ya eu des ordonnances très précisément
les larmes
si les détenus ont qui sont confrontés
et qui ont été confrontés voient
appliquer dans une infernale tourist qui
s'ils ont été libérés
c'est parce qu'ils sont enfin le pen et
s'ils sont en fin de peine il peut ils
peuvent avoir effectivement des mesures
de contrôle judiciaire
lorsqu'ils seront mis en liberté mais
c'est uniquement dans ce cas de figure
mais il est bien évident que ce serait
pas acceptable qui a détenu même s'il
est en fin de peine soit libéré
lorsqu'il a commis par exemple des
violences sur les forces de l'ordre sur
les surveillants pénitentiaires
lorsqu'il a commis des violences assez
assez importante et avec des victimes
qui peuvent être toujours présent dans
l'environnement
ça c'est pas acceptable par contre
libérer un détenu il lui reste par
exemple quelques semaines a effectué par
ce qu'il a commis des vols ou parce que
effectivement il a commis un délit qui
met qui met pas en jeu leur public
on peut le comprendre on peut le
comprendre dans la conjoncture actuelle
et puis retardée effectivement
l'exécution des peines lorsque c'est pas
nécessaire c'est également une décision
que nous pouvons comprendre
donc moi j'essaie d'être pragmatique et
je pense que si les ordonnances du et
les directives du garde des sceaux sont
appliqués à la lettre je pense qu'il y
aura mobilisé
normalement il n'y a pas de difficulté à
la matière mais il faut que ce soit bien
appliquée il faut effectivement les
autorités pénitentiaires et judiciaires
soient tout à fait vigilant lorsque ils
prennent la décision de libérer un
détenu en fin de peine
merci beaucoup
kim hyo députés ps d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france les pays de
l'opep se réunissent aujourd'hui par
visioconférence avec d'autres grands
producteurs de pétrole dont la russie
est la précédente réunion début mars
était soldée par un échec
objectif aujourd'hui stabilisé les prix
alors que la demande en pétrole baisse à
cause de l'épidémie du corps d'un virus
est membre de l'organisation des pays
exportateurs de pétrole et d'autres pays
producteurs à espère arriver un accord
pour rétablir l'équilibré marché est
aussi décidé d'une réduction massive de
la production mondiale de son côté
donald trump a déclaré que les
producteurs américains avait déjà réduit
leur production il dit disposer
d'options si l'arabie saoudite et la
russie venait à ne pas trouver d'accord
je ne pense pas à regarder nous avons
déjà fait des coupes
nous sommes très orientée vers le marché
si vous regardez les impôts si vous
regardez le dakota du nord et d'autres
de nos états ils font cela très bien ils
ont déjà réduit ils l'ont réduite
automatiquement oui mais les précisions
de notre correspondant à moscou antoine
gayraud bien interrogé sur le sujet le
porte-parole du kremlin a refusé de
commenter la déclaration du président
américain
signe que le sujet délicat il s'est
borné à rappeler la position de vladimir
poutine comme quoi une stabilisation des
cours du pétrole ne sera pas possible
sans une participation de tous les
grands pays producteurs
l'objectif de cette réunion cruciale de
l'opep en format élargi et de convaincre
les pays participants à réduire leur
production d'environ 10 voire peut-être
même 15 millions de barils soit à peu
près 10% de la production mondiale afin
de stabiliser les prix et les faire
repartir à la hausse
pour ce faire les russes comme les
saoudiens sont prêts à négocier de
nouveau à la condition donc que les
autres pays producteurs hors-opep comme
la norvège le canada ou les états unis
mettent eux aussi la main à la pâte et
participe à l'effort collectif
la position de washington sera scruté de
très près au cours actuel l'industrie
pétrolière américaine se trouve en
grande difficulté et la situation est
extrêmement volatile le report de cette
réunion chaque déclaration qui va dans
le sens d'un accord ou bien dans le sens
contraire se ressent immédiatement sur
le cours du baril
brent un indice qui a touché son plus
bas niveau depuis 2002 et même bouclé le
pire trimestre de son histoire
l'ensemble des acteurs du secteur
attendons que cette vision conférence
d'aujourd'hui mais aussi la réunion des
ministres de l'énergie du g20 de demain
viennent inverser la tendance et pour en
parler nous sommes avec alexandre kateb
économiste et spécialiste des économies
émergentes bonsoir alexandre kateb merci
d'être avec nous on dirait que sur rt
fonce une réunion a eu donc lui
aujourd'hui entre les principaux pays
producteurs de pétrole et leurs
partenaires donc que doit-on retenir de
cette réunion cette réunion aux fêtes
était attendue par tous les participants
je crois elle s'est fait sous la
pression des états unis qui ont intérêt
à ce que les prix ne chute pas en deçà
des niveaux actuels et également de
l'arabie saoudite qui en fait on l a
déclenché cette guerre des prix et à
inonder le marché avec une offre
supplémentaire ne s'attendait pas du
tout à ce que les prix chutent en raison
de la crise du port aux navires us et
qu'on se retrouve aujourd'hui dans une
situation où il n'y a quasiment pas de
capacité de stockage et je sais ce que
craignent et tous les participants à
cette réunion c'est qu'à un moment donné
en fin de compte le prix du pétrole a et
jusqu'à 0 voire soient négatifs parce
qu'en fait les producteurs devront
quelque part payer pour que le pétrole
soit ils ont ponctionné quoi alors terre
qui coince quel est le point
d'achoppement dans ces négociations
le point d'achoppement principal c'est
qu'on fait les participants n'ont pas du
tout la même notion sur l'idée de
réduction des capacités est ce que cela
implique pour les états unis il ya déjà
une réduction de capacités naturelles
sur le marché qui est liée à la chute de
la demande de l'ordre de 25 à 30%
aujourd'hui sur le marché intérieur
américain et donc les américains disent
que de toute manière ils vont réduire
leurs capacités de production mais
se disent non nous ne voulons pas de
cette réduction spontanée nous voulons
des objectifs fixés par l'état qui soit
contraignant et que tout le monde
respecte ses objectifs pour pouvoir
évaluer en fait justement le respect de
l'accord qui sera à prix sinon ça n'a
pas d'effectivité quelles conséquences
sur le consommateur sur les
consommateurs que nous sommes de cette
situation de mésentente entre ces
différents pays
en temps normal disons que quand le prix
du pétrole chutent les consommateurs
devraient plutôt se réjouir
sauf que là on c'est une situation de
confinement et même si on va sortir du
confinement de manière très graduelle en
fin de compte les déplacements ne vont
pas reprendre très fortement et donc les
consommateurs ne tire pas vraiment
avantage de cette situation et sa des
répercussions sur la confiance en fait
économique parce que le pétrole est
souvent un indicateur de la de la
croissance et donc des prix très bas
voire des prix qui pourrait atteindre 10
dollars le baril indiquerait un
effondrement total de l'économie
mondiale et donc dans ce cas de figure
les consommateurs seraient aussi
impactées par cette perte générale de
confiance alors l'objectif effectivement
être une coupe commune de 10 à 15
millions de barils par jour c'est ce
qu'a confirmé le ministre koweïtien du
pétrole
est ce que ça vous paraît possible c'est
possible si vraiment il ya un effort qui
est fait par tous les pays participants
pour disons faire des sacrifices et et
réduire dans des proportions
substantielle leurs propres productions
ça veut dire que les états unis le
canada doivent aussi y participer
et il faut aussi que les pays
consommateurs quelque part participent à
cet effort notamment à travers leurs
stocks stratégiques qu'ils doivent
remplir et qu'ils doivent à
thione pour fonctionner une partie de
cette offre excédentaire qui est sur le
marché aujourd'hui
merci là où alexandre kateb économiste
spécialiste des économies émergentes
d'avoir été avec nous l'europe divisés
sur la réponse économique à la crise du
coronavirus les ministres des finances
de la zone euro continue de se diviser
sur les moyens à mettre en oeuvre face à
la récession qui s'annonce la pire
depuis 1945
retour au mécanisme européen de
stabilité corona vance impliquant une
mutualisation des dettes
les blocages sont nombreux alors qu
peut-on encore attend de lui et de ses
institutions dans cette crise est ce que
l'on voit tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir en direct par
skype bonsoir jacques un confinement
oblige vous êtes loin de moi est loin de
ce plateau j'espère que vous allez bien
quand même jeanne bonsoir beaucoup vous
aussi je le regrette et donc nous allons
travailler par sky exactement alors
jacquin on al impression qu en europe a
le pouvoir et est revenu aux états dans
cette crise c'est également votre
sentiment
eh bien oui stéphanie il est clair que
les centres de décision sont aujourd'hui
bien plus dans les capitales de chaque
état qu'à bruxelles
ça ne veut pourtant pas dire que l'union
européenne soit complètement impuissante
et là j'y mets énergie très timidement
et il faut le lire avec beaucoup de
retard alors elle a certes pris des
mesures comme la suppression des droits
de douanes communautaire à l'importation
de matériel médical c'est très bien mais
c'est très peu et en fait le problème
c'est que les questions qui sont posées
par cette épidémie ont réactivé des
débats internes qui ne sont toujours pas
résolus et rien ne dit qu au vu de la
dernière réunion de l'eurogroupe qui
puisse être réglé rapidement
alors jacques à que s'est il donc à
passer en ce début de semaine lors de la
réunion de l'eurogroupe
il faut commencer par rappeler que
l'eurogroupe qui réunit les
gouvernements des pays de la zone euro
on n'a pas d'existence légale il n'est
mentionné en tant que tel dans aucun
traité c'est pourtant l'une est une
instance alors une instance de fait et
non une instance de droit qui est très
importante et pour la zone euro bien
entendu mais aussi pour l'union
européenne
alors la réunion qui a eu lieu bon ces
derniers jours devaient notamment
discuter de la proposition franco
italienne d'émettre ce que l'on appelle
des corona bon alors évidemment
pouvez-vous jacquin vous voyez la
question arrivait que se cache sous ce
nom barbare pas barbare mais
d'appellation de corona monde
oui on comprend ses fans y aller corona
bon c'est quelque chose qui va être liés
à l'épidémie du coronavirus alors par
kuroda bon on entend des bons du trésor
qui seraient émis directement par
l'union européenne ou un autre organisme
par exemple dépendant de la zone euro
pour trouver de l'argent qui serait
alors mis à la disposition des
différents pays de l'union européenne ou
de la zone euro ce qui fait que ces pays
pourraient emprunter aux taux les plus
bas et non pas au tout qu'ils doivent
payer s'ils veulent s'endetter
directement en fait c'est un mécanisme
qui revient dans les faits à une
mutualisation des dettes
c'est d'ailleurs une vieille demande de
la france et de l'italie
on avait commencé à en parler de cette
fameuse mutualisation des dettes dans un
contexte tout à fait différent lors de
la crise des pays du sud de la zone euro
en 2010 2011 et qu'à décider
l'eurogroupe et bien stéphanie pour
l'instant je dis bien pour l'instant
rien du tout l'allemagne l'autriche les
pays-bas ont jusqu'à maintenant bloquer
les corona bon alors ça montre que les
possibilités sont en fait très limité on
sait bien que le confinement est en
train de provoquer une crise historique
une crise terrible dans les économies
cette crise qu aura donc aussi et c'est
une évidence une traduction budgétaire
très importante il faudra d'après une
étude d'unicredit trouvé entre 1000 et
me
300 milliards d'euros supplémentaires
pour les budgets des différents pays par
exemple il faudra trouver quelque chose
comme au moins 300 milliards pour la
france et probablement une somme à peu
près similaire pour l'italie ou utilise
pas les couronnes ah bon il faudra à ce
moment là pensez au mécanisme européen
de stabilité le ms alors de quoi
s'agit-il au juste
le ms stéphanie c'est ce qu'on a appelé
un temps le fameux fmi européen
c'est avec l iphone qui permet à l'union
européenne de prêter des sommes
importantes à des états l'espagne la
grèce ont pu en bénéficier
mais bien entendu sous des conditions
qui sont très sévères le ms
il est à l'origine des fameux mémorandum
qui ont été imposées au gouvernement
grec
à partir de 2012 et c'est pour cela que
le ms n'a pas très bonne réputation
effectivement et donc ce mécanisme
jacques que l'on voudrait imposer à des
pays comme l'italie et la france ont
fait la france et l'italie seraient
d'accord pour que l'on active le ms
colon qu'on leur en force parce que le
ms pour l'instant n'est prévu qu'avec
400 milliards d'euros ce qui est très
insuffisant par rapport aux besoins
mais à la condition justement qu'ils
soient sans condition tu fais de la
situation exceptionnelle qui a été créée
par l'épidémie du coronavirus mais ici
encore l'allemagne les pays-bas et puis
d'autres pays refusent cette idée d'un
ms sans condition alors la commission
européenne a proposé une forme de
compromis à m us avec des conditions
adoucie mais pour l'instant la france et
l'italie ont refusé
mais alors que peut faire l'union
européenne dans ces conditions alors
l'union européenne a fait une
proposition pour financer par exemple le
chômage partiel qui d'ailleurs rien
qu'en france touche désormais
pratiquement six millions de personnes à
ce jour
elle propose de créer un instrument le s
u r e sur cet instrument prendra la
forme d'un prêt adossé à des garanties
fournies par là encore les différents
états membres de l'union européenne
seulement le gouvernement italien a déjà
déclaré qu'il n'était pas favorable à ce
mécanisme qui lui semble à la fois lourd
coûteux et qu'il préfère en réalité les
grenats bon alors les corona bon ni les
allemands sont là bien compris ni les
néerlandais n'en vol fin d'histoire donc
alors oui et non parce que en réalité il
y à d'autres d'autres possibilités
prenons par exemple le cas de la banque
centrale européenne christine lagarde a
sorti les grands moyens tout d'abord
pour soulager les entreprises mais aussi
les banques qui sont très durement
attaqué ces derniers temps sur les
marchés financiers elle a décidé
d'accroître le programme de la bce de
rachat des dettes privées
ensuite elle a mis en place un programme
spécial
le ppp alors ça veut dire le pandémique
et madden ses potes choisi un programme
doté pour l'instant de 750 milliards
d'euros et qui va racheter directement
la dette émise par les états sont tenir
compte des limites qui avait été fixé en
alors jacques ce n'est pas un peu une
forme de création monétaire interdite
si je ne m'abuse par les statuts et de
la bce oui stefanik c'est évident sauf
que tous les interdits ont de fait
sauter les uns après les autres que ce
soit en 2010 2013 lors de la crise
d'endettement des pays du sud de la zone
euro que ce soit en 2015 avec la
politique de mario draghi vous savez le
le le fameux bazooka monétaire que ce
soit aujourd'hui
alors il est clair que la bce est en
train de s'aventurer dans des eaux qui
sont encore largement inexploré et elle
pourrait d'ailleurs être rappelé à
l'ordre par une action en justice d'un
ou de plusieurs des états membres vous
pensez peut-être à l'allemagne
bien sûr mais il n'y a pas que
l'allemagne qui pourrait réagir
vous avez les pays-bas vous avez la
finlande alors jacquel bilan tirez vous
de cela
eh bien c'est fini l'idée d'une union
européenne fédérale vous savez c'est
cette idée qui est défendu
par exemple en france par emmanuel
macron a probablement été l'une des
victimes collatérales du coronavirus
l'évier d'opposition et parfois il faut
bien le dire malheureusement les
vieilles haines
on est immédiatement ressurgit devant la
crise les politiques ont été
immédiatement renationaliser les
gouvernements des six puis ils viennent
présenter la facture à bruxelles ou à
francfort
mais la coordination entre les
politiques gouvernementales est
aujourd'hui extrêmement difficile et
nous vivons en fait une crise historique
temps de la construction européenne que
de la zone euro merci jacques pour
toutes ces explications qui donne comme
d'habitude a réfléchi à merci à vous
merci à vous c'est fini et pour finir
cette émission va prendre un petit peu
de hauteur quelques images de la fusée
soyouz deux cosmonautes et astronautes
ont eu la bonne idée de décoller
aujourd'hui parfait que perfect timing
c'est j'ose dire en direction de la
station spatiale internationale
ils laissent derrière eux évidemment la
planète bleue confronté à cette pandémie
due qu'aux vives 19 confinés dans les
étoiles
c'est ce qui attend donc cette équipe
pour les prochains mois on les envie un
petit peu je vous laisse voilà mon
méditer sur ces images excellente fin de
soirée à tous
en tout cas émission évidemment vous le
savez écourter le temps check list du
coronavirus qui vous pousse nous adapter
évidemment nous aussi comme tous les
autres médias
un prochain journal ce sera demain matin
9 heures du matin heure française
[Musique]